there's a great story uh told by nelson
mandela which i think is a good lesson
you're asking for a specific tip um uh
he was actually born the son of a tribal
chief and when asked by a journalist
you know uh how did you become a great
leader and as an aside
nelson mandela is a very important case
study because different personalities
are viewed differently depending on
where you go in the world but nelson
mandela
regardless of where you go in the world
is universally regarded as a great
leader so he's an important case for
for for folks like me um uh and he was
asked
by a journalist how did you learn to
become a great leader and he said
when i was a boy i remember two things
i remember going to tribal meetings with
my father
and i remember uh that he they always
sat in a circle
and my father was always the last to
speak
um and if you think he's the most senior
person in the room he's this tribal
chief and he was always the last to
speak
you know we're constantly telling people
you have to be a better listener but at
the end of the day we have to speak
eventually and when we communicate
but i think the practice of being the
last to speak when you're in a meeting
we do this all the time the senior
person comes and goes okay
even well-intentioned you know this is
the problem this is the challenge we
have this is what i think we should do
but i'm interested in what you have to
say well it's too late you buy us the
room it's over
or you've made people feel that their
opinion doesn't matter and so for
leaders to practice
listening and this is a and by the way
i'm tired of the term soft skills
hard skills are the skills we need to
learn to do our jobs and human skills
are the learn
of the skills we need to be better human
beings and it's the combination of hard
skills and human skills
that make us very good and listening is
one of those so i think
be coming into a meeting stating a
problem not giving an opinion
not playing poker not letting anybody
know what you think as they speak
asking questions only out of curiosity
not to you know push somebody in one
direction or another
and literally be the last to speak not
only do you make people feel
like their opinions matter but you get
the benefit of of new ideas
you can still make the same decision you
wanted to make at the beginning but you
get all that additional
benefit so practice being the last to
speak that's a great lesson